Oh
[Music]
superheroes
we can't relate to it none of us can
slide sir Superman's like an alien from
a different planet to us you know we've
been lied to
okay what we need is a superhero that
makes us all feel like we could be
superheroes enter the de constantly
right there you hear is super power it's
in is me see I don't care what kind of
bad guy you are I don't care how evil
you are you're gonna stop whatever
wrongdoings you're doing
once the decosta pay to start you're
doing thank you to concentrator and what
superhero is complete without an
arch-nemesis exactly that's where the
blackout Barrett comes in he has the
power to sleep with anyone as long as
they're both blackout drunk
luckily the constipated will stop at
nothing until they give the blackout
Varun's the ultimate booty call so
what's your feeling on there so you
think in my in a Michael Bay blockbuster
or maybe captain Bigelow award sweet
because I'm I'm even considering like
Netflix series if I sent that script to
any director about a superhero called as
a constipated they used it to wipe their
ass better name I see what you're saying
better name I'm with you on that okay
put my sister all right to your bed
better yet off all right off
good to see you anyway just still hurry
up I think I saw that I think I
sold